moin moin großes beben beim big city
club in berlin jürgen klinsmann führte
ein geheimes protokoll aus zehn wochen
hertha bsc das liegt uns vor wurde
abgedruckt in der sport bild es liest
sich wie ein tagebuch wir haben es
angesprochen als hörbuch so könnt ihr
jetzt auch noch mal nach hören ihr könnt
es entweder kaufen in der sport-bild ihr
könnt es lesen auf bild.de per bild plus
oder euch per hörbuch anhören auch per
bild plus wie das ganze funktioniert
seht ihr dann gleich im abspann hier mal
ein kleiner auszug schon mal aus dem
hörbuch viel spaß
jürgen klinsmann 55 jahre war 76 tage
trainer bevor er am 11 februar hinwarf
bei der hertha klinsmann hat ein
protokoll seiner zeit bei hertha bsc
verfassen lassen was sich wie ein
tagebuch liest und in der aktuellen
sport bild enthüllt wurde
zusammenfassung zehn wochen hertha bsc
sportliche bestandsaufnahme mannschaft
in einem katastrophalen körperlichen wie
mentalen zustand der kader ist von der
altersstruktur her völlig falsch
zusammengestellt zu viele ältere satte
spieler die keinerlei power haben um im
abstiegskampf zu bestehen kalou zu alt
duda sattlecker satt und immer verletzt
die bise witsch zu alt jahr steil
fraglich und so weiter der club wäre
ohne den trainerwechsel ende november
direkt in die zweite liga abgestiegen
weil er auf diese situation gar nicht
vorbereitet ist
was muss passieren um diesen klub
wirklich nach oben zu bringen die
geschäftsleitung muss sofort komplett
ausgetauscht werden
sollte dies nicht passieren werden auch
die tollen neuzugänge nach einer
gewissen zeit zu durchschnitt spielern
weil es die grundregel auch im fußball
gibt du bist nur so gut wie dein umfeld
die spieler passen sich zweifelsohne dem
niveau des clubs an nicht umgekehrt